[Music]  thrilled to announce  mit cass virtual visiting artist program  bringing together three of the most  vibrant artists in the musical scene  today  don byron  [Music]  this year-long program involves a  symbiotic relationship between the  artists  mit students faculty and community  exploring new artistic and pedagogical  terrain  offering a tapestry of wide-ranging  interactive and interdisciplinary  experiences during this challenging  period of kovid the opportunity for our  students and community to develop  personal connections with  artists and people of this magnitude is  invaluable  we look forward to all the deep and  enriching opportunities ahead